president trump is back on the campaign
trail
this time in georgia trying to prevent
democrats from taking control
of the senate kelly's opponent rafael
warnock
is a dangerous extremist who is
radically opposed to your values
he said he believes that quote nobody
can serve god
and the military oh really
an appalling statement that dishonors
the memory and
generations of american heroes who
fought for god
and for our country rafael warnock
has openly declared his support for
socialism
and he has even praised marxists all
over the world
he once hosted the barbaric communist
dictator
fidel castro lex castro i think he was a
good man he was a good guy he said
he falsely slandered patriotic americans
as racists
he called police officers gangsters
thugs and bullies
he supports abolishing cash bail look at
what happened to new york with their
cash bail no cash ban don't bail don't
worry about it you killed somebody don't
worry about it you know
you're on the honor code you're on the
honor code
that's true and that frankly that's only
a fraction
of the radicalism that we've seen from
warnock this
georgia senate race these two georgia
center races are going to be
extraordinarily important because the
georgia races are not over
the presidential race is not even over
we've got updates on all of it i'm
michael knowles that's the michael
knowles show
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment from last friday on our first
friday show
is from daryl fortune who says when
someone asks me why i'm not wearing a
mask
i always ask in response why is yours
not working why are you so concerned
about my mask i thought you're wearing a
mask
i thought the masks work now of course
what the left says is no no it
you don't wear the mask to protect you
you wear the mask to protect everybody
else but actually we've got some video
evidence of the left
contradicting this point because really
the masks are not about protecting me
and they're not about protecting you
they are about raw political power and
we've seen around the country
people are getting fed up with it even
in the most left-wing
places there is a lot of uncertainty
right now
there is a lot of chaos going on right
now
and it's why when we're thinking of how
to respond to all of these political
questions
you also want to make sure you've got
pretty stable investments here's
something new
you know that the price of gold has been
skyrocketing lately
well now there is a way to buy gold
through a company called acre
now the issue with investing in gold i
love investing in physical metals and
i've done it for years
the issue with investing in gold is that
gold is very expensive
so usually we don't have thousands of
dollars lying around to start buying
gold bars
well acre has come up with a way for you
to subscribe to gold bars
for as little as thirty dollars a month
how is that possible gold costs more
than thirty dollars
well what you do is you pay each month
once your gold stash reaches the price
of their gold bars
they will discreetly ship acre gold to
your house acre lets you invest in
physical gold without
coming out of pocket all at once acre
then keeps you updated on your gold
stash every month
and it ships once you reach the price
threshold acres physical delivery of
your gold means that it is safe
and sound and in your hands that's
something you can rely on they also just
recently introduced their new hundred
dollar per month subscription to their
five gram
gold bar i really enjoy investing
in physical metal i like having it in my
hands knowing it's safe and secure
visit getacregold.com knowles right now
start investing in physical gold today
make sure that you go to this url
because acre is giving away a gold bar
to qualify for the giveaway tweet or
post why you should be the recipient and
mention at
get underscore acre that is
getacregold.com
knowles and thank you akergold for
supporting the show
president trump down in georgia to help
out with these senate races i hope
that this can put an end to a canard
that i've been hearing
from critics of donald trump for the
past several weeks namely
that trump doesn't care at all about
republicans keeping the senate
namely that trump doesn't mind if
loffler and perdue lose in georgia that
he's only in it for himself he's not
trying to help the greater cause
trump contrary to what some
lawyers who are helping donald trump
have been saying trump has consistently
told people to go
vote in the georgia races he has not
told people to sit out the georgia races
and he's gone down there to campaign
he is helping out in the senate race
very good
he is also simultaneously pursuing
legal resource recourse rather in the
presidential race
you can do two things at once this was
something we talked about last week it
seems that there is one group of people
that says we need to only focus on the
presidential race
forget about georgia and there's another
group of people that say we've got to
hold the senate we've got to focus on
georgia forget about the presidential
race
give that up one side is willing to
throw out the senate
the other side wants trump to concede
prematurely why can't we do both at once
that's what trump is doing and i think
that's what we should be doing too
the fact that president trump is
unwilling
on today december 7th to concede
the presidential race a day which will
live in infamy
according to the mainstream media if if
trump doesn't concede
this is driving these mainstream
journalists crazy take a listen alex
azor the hhs secretary
went on fox news sunday this weekend and
talked to chris wallace who you will
remember
did not appear to be very friendly to
president trump at that presidential
debate
so he goes on and he's referring to
president trump he's referring to
former vice president joe biden chris
wallace
cannot tolerate that alex azar will not
concede the race on behalf of trump
if president trump had worn a mask then
and urged everyone to wear a mask then
back in april
the way joe biden is right now wouldn't
we be in much better shape
well chris i i i welcome vice president
biden to the club since the middle of
april the president's guidelines for
reopening have called
an alexa the president has called the
president
the president has called mass patriotic
acts
every one of his top advisors we are out
there saying wear your mass
we talk about the data you know chris at
one meter if two people wear the mass it
can reduce viral transmission by
72 protecting both the source
and the recipient we've got the data
mass work we encourage people
please wear a mask when you can't engage
in social distancing
but but first of all it's it's the
president-elect joe biden secretary azar
uh first of all it isn't president-elect
joe biden
joe biden is not the president elect
he simply isn't chris wallace should
have a warning label
when he when he posts this clip on
facebook or on twitter
saying that this claim is fake news or
at the very least this claim is disputed
had the election come out and the media
declared the election for
joe biden and then donald trump conceded
i guess it would be fair to call joe
biden the president-elect even though
the electors hadn't voted yet but that's
not what happened
this is a hotly contested presidential
election there were lawsuits working
their way through courts
very likely up to the supreme court the
electors have not voted
meaning that as a technical matter we we
simply do not have a president-elect
but because no one's conceded this
because the election is disputed
there is no argument whatsoever for
calling joe biden the president-elect
unless you are a partisan who is trying
to
confuse the public about a debated and
contested
presidential election which is obviously
what chris wallace is doing this is
something that that very few people
pointed out
on twitter when twitter had the the line
it said
this claim is disputed this right they
only put that
on president trump's tweets
but a friend of mine jim o'neil pointed
this out
that if a claim is disputed
then you ought to put the disputed label
on
on both sides of the claim so if donald
trump comes out and says
we won this election and joe biden comes
out and says we won this election
if the claim that trump won is disputed
then that means that the claim that
biden won is disputed too
so you're supposed to put the label on
both but of course the media don't want
to do that because when they say
disputed
they mean it's disputed by us when they
say sources have called this election
differently
the sources they're referring to are
themselves and they
want to make themselves the official
authority for this even though they are
not
the the courts have some authority here
the president has some authority if he
were to concede
and the electors of course who will be
voting not many days from now
have authority as well also knocking
down
chris wallace's insistence that joe
biden is the president-elect
is the supreme court so just yesterday
this is some big news on the trump legal
front
sam alito supreme court justice asked
officials in pennsylvania to file briefs
by tomorrow morning by tuesday morning
in response to an emergency injunction
petition
filed by republicans seeking to
invalidate or rescind the results of the
november third election in the keystone
state
so i just did an episode with senator
cruz
on our show verdict about this issue
of all of the claims of election fraud
or illegality or unconstitutionality
the clearest example of this is
pennsylvania the pennsylvania state
constitution
prohibits the use of widespread
unsolicited mail-in ballots the kind of
ballots that we saw in this election
it explicitly prohibits their use you
gotta vote in person there are some
narrow carve outs but you have to vote
in person there
the legislature in pennsylvania
overrode this and they said no you can
vote by mail
widespread mail-in but the legislature
does not have the authority to override
the constitution
now the pennsylvania supreme court came
in and in a highly partisan and
indefensible
opinion said oh never mind forget about
the constitution have your mail in
ballots
and enjoy however you're going to count
them down there in philly guys
there is now a petition going to the u.s
supreme court
to invalidate those
results because they were patently
unconstitutional
that is a very legitimate argument
however there is a deadline for these
things because
we need to know where the electors are
going before they go and vote
so initially this deadline was go or
initially rather the supreme court was
maybe gonna hear this thursday would
have been too late
so they've reached this safe harbor
deadline what this seems to suggest
is that the supreme court is going to
weigh in on the election in pennsylvania
now that wouldn't be enough to flip the
presidential election
you'd also have to flip georgia and
you'd have to flip arizona is that
possible i suppose it is possible
is it likely it's not likely however
however it's worth pointing out
it is not impossible the trump team is
still pursuing their legal options
actually our friend jenna ellis who is
president trump's lawyer has come out
and
given a news of great progress in
in the legal fight and this could be the
way maybe the only way
to flip the votes in georgia and
arizona which is they need to prove
that there was something fishy about the
vote
counting machines we've heard the names
smartmatic we've heard the names
dominion we've heard all of these sorts
of
rumors going around about software
hacking manipulation now we're going to
find out
whether that's legitimate or not because
we could get a forensic audit here
we've got to listen to jenna ellis's
argument
and if you want to listen to it in a
really wonderful way i'd highly
recommend you listen on raycon
you know another way that 2020 has
thrown us for a loop
of course is going to be this holiday
shopping season after everything that's
gone on this year
you want to make sure that every single
person on your list gets a gift that
will actually
make them say hey thank you i needed
this this is really improving my year
it's been a little tough
the silver bullet gift idea raycon
wireless earbuds with seamless bluetooth
pairing and a comfortable noise
isolating fit
you can start listening right out of the
box and keep listening for hours the
audio quality is
phenomenal it's comparable to what you
get with other premium brands except
that raycon start
at half the price i have a whole bunch
of different wireless earbuds i've got
raycons i've got the expensive ones that
you all know about i've got the other
expensive ones
and i try them on i got to tell you the
other ones have problems
recons very very reliable and much less
expensive
raycon is being generous for the
holidays so on top of their everyday
great prices they are offering our
listeners 15
off right now go to buy raycon.com
knowles know wlas
get 15 off your raycon order that is by
raycon
dot com slash knowles buy raycon dot com
slash knowles k
w l e s so now once we all affix
our raycon wireless earbuds we can
listen to jenna's argument because
this is maybe a little bit of a hail
mary but there is a chance
that this could flip the results the big
news
coming out of interim county michigan
this morning pete is that a judge
actually granted our team access to 22
of the dominion voting machines for us
to conduct a forensic audit
so if you remember this is the county
that had this switch of
6 000 votes from president trump to joe
biden
and that was an unexplained and
so-called glitch and so our team is
going to be able to go in this morning
at about 8 30
and we'll be there for about eight hours
to conduct that forensic examination and
we'll have the results in about 48 hours
and that'll tell us a lot about these
machines so we'll find out later this
week
if there is any substance to the claims
that dominion
and the other software have flipped the
votes
now this is happening because of a judge
in michigan of course if there is some
sort of
systemic issue with the software then
that's going to affect
the certification of the results in
other states
as well some people passionately believe
that these voting machines were rigged
they see the glitches such as thousands
of ballots being flipped
for somebody else they see spikes in the
count and they say
this looks pretty fishy they know that
these electronic voting machines are
vulnerable just by definition
compared to older methods of voting so
they look at that and they say
absolutely there was a
rigged election going on through the
machines then there are other people who
say this is crazy
this is a conspiracy theory there's no
chance that there any of the machines
were rigged come on you get your tin
foil hat off
as always in this election fight there
is an option between these two extremes
the option is okay if you're so
convinced it's a conspiracy theory
let us go in and take a look at the
machines
if if you're so convinced this is a then
don't then don't wipe the machines there
was a judge order in georgia
not to allow people to wipe the dominion
voting machines and reset them cool
there's no problem then we're going to
go in there
and take a look at what's going on in
those machines likewise
for people who were convinced there was
rigging okay if you're so convinced
we'll go into the machines
we'll see if there's rigging time is
running out because we live in
space and time right we don't this isn't
gonna drag on for
eight or ten years frankly even if there
was fraud if you can't prove it in the
amount of time it doesn't matter
i often go back to the case of lyndon
johnson who stole his senate seat in
1948 we now can know that
with certainty and we figured it out
around 1990 for sure that he stole it
well okay we got it that's a moral
victory except he'd already served in
the senate he was already vice president
he was already
already president and he already
transformed the country through his
political career
but there just we didn't prove it in
time so we're going to find out
as jenna says we should know within 48
hours fine by me i'm more than happy to
exercise
the virtue of patience and say we're
gonna
see what happens here more than happy to
exercise the virtue of courage and
resist
calls to concede the election even if
the mainstream media even if the
putatively
conservative cable news channel is
insisting that we do that
and we'll let the legal process play out
now there is some sad news
one of president trump's top legal
advisors
just got coronavirus rudy giuliani has
tested positive for coronavirus
rudy is older he's 76 years old
he's not exactly in olympic shape you
know i mean he's just an older guy who's
a lawyer you know he's not a marathon
runner or something
so uh we hope that he recovers of course
we hope he's doing very well
a number of blue check marks a number of
liberal
opinion makers when this news came out
suggested it was bs said it was a cover
that actually look rudy has been flying
all over the place he hasn't been
wearing a mask he's been shaking
rudy got covid months ago okay he's
obviously already had it
and multiple blue check marks have been
suggesting this
the reason that they're saying he got it
now is to kick him off the team because
he's not doing a great job
i i have no interest in
hypothesizing and sort of going through
this gossip mill
my only point on the blue check marks
argument here is
it undercuts their alarmism
if they're saying that actually rudy
giuliani secretly got covered months ago
but nobody knew about it he recovered he
was totally fine it was just a little
cough or something
then why are we shutting down the world
over this virus
if our fast food chomping physical
exercise issuing 74 year old president
gets the virus and recovers in three
days
why are we shutting down the world over
this virus if the virus has
a far greater than 99 survival rate
why are we shutting down the world over
this virus i think the left
and they do this a lot they
attack the conservative position from
opposite perspectives
they just use any cudgel they possibly
can
at their disposal you know either they
did this with george bush especially
they do it with trump too they'll say
he's a he's a dumb
idiot he's a dunce he's the stupidest
[ __ ] who's ever been and that's why
we've got to get him out of office
also he's an evil genius also he's the
greatest
evil genius kgb agent that's
worked his way up through the sheer
brilliance
of his mad wicked mind and that's why
we've got to kick him out of office
obviously those things are contradictory
they just throw them at the same time
especially with donald trump but you've
seen it with other republicans too
so that's what they're saying here
they're saying coronavirus is
look it's so irresponsible all these
people in the president's orbit
have gotten coronavirus that's why we've
we've got to shut down the country but
also rudy giuliani he's a liar
rudy giuliani already had coronavirus
okay now he's covering it up now
and that's why we need to kick president
trump out of office those those two
justifications for different political
ends on the left
contradict one another they they don't
realize that it cuts against their
alarmist arguments they don't realize
how incoherent the lockdown measures
appear but people are getting fed up
with it and it's not just
conservatives and talking heads and
republican politicians
it's not it's regular old people people
who own businesses
people who are in very blue places
california la la land especially
under mayor garcetti's control has
locked down again
this was after restaurants shut down
and they reopened and they were told
they had to go outside they invest lots
and lots of money friend of mine
who works for a restaurant in la said
they invested a hundred thousand dollars
turning their parking lot into an
outdoor area to eat
that was just shut down again too so
they're locking all that down meanwhile
though
the pet projects of these politicians
are allowed to continue undeterred there
was a woman in los angeles
who stands to lose everything she's a
restaurant owner who points out
that the politicians shut down her
business
but they permitted almost an identical
type of business to operate
right next door so this is my place the
pineapple hill grill and saloon
if you go to my page you can see all the
work i did for outdoor dining
for tables being seven feet apart and i
come in today
because i'm organizing a protest and i
came in to get
stuff for that and i walk
into my parking lot and obviously mayor
garcetti has approved
this
has approved
this being set up for this
being set up for for a movie company
so if if you can
see this this is an open area giant
tents
big tables because la is a show business
town so they want to be able to make
movies and when you make movies you need
these areas for people to eat
and hang out so they set up functionally
an outdoor
restaurant right next to
an outdoor restaurant they said no the
outdoor restaurant has to shut down but
the movie theater the
the the movie production set
may remain open why well i don't know
because the restaurants spread
coronavirus but the movies do not
you might say all those incompetent
politicians oh they just don't think
about it oh how silly how ridiculous
it's not just silly it's not just
something to laugh at
many many people are going to lose
everything
they're going to lose their life savings
they're going to lose their business
many many many people are going to be
put out of work because these capricious
politicians
can't let go of power they can't let go
of their
ability to arbitrarily decide what
succeeds and what fails and what people
are allowed to do
which changes every hour of the day and
this woman is rightly
furious i'm losing everything
everything i own is being taken away
from me and they set up a movie company
right next to my outdoor patio which is
right over here
and people wonder why i'm protesting
and why i have had enough
they have not given us money and they
have shut us down we cannot survive
my staff cannot survive look at this
tell me that this is dangerous
but right next to me as a slap in my
face
that's safe this is safe
50 feet away
this is dangerous mayor garcetti and
gavin newsom is responsible
for every single person that doesn't
have unemployment
that does not have a job and all the
businesses that are going under
and we need your help we need somebody
to do something about this absolutely
right
this is maybe the most ridiculous
example of this you've seen but you've
seen
other examples of this from the
beginning here you have
actually two of identical operations
one is now illegal one of them is legal
and actually if it's movies it's
probably being subsidized in part by the
government
that's ridiculous but you've seen it
from the beginning you're allowed to go
out and
riot for blm but you're not allowed to
go to church why because blm
and woke-ism and political correctness
is the established religion of the
the liberal state and christianity and
judaism
are are repressed and suppressed
religion so you're allowed to go to the
good religion you're not allowed to go
to the politically incorrect religion
obviously we can't rely on these
politicians we can't rely on their
expert analysis we can't rely on their
advice so we got to rely on ourselves
now is a better time than ever
to be prepared with long-term
nutritional food options
ready wise makes being prepared simple
and affordable you order online you have
nutritious meals shipped directly to
your doorstep
ready wise makes being prepared simple
and affordable order online have
nutritious meals shipped
directly to your doorstep when preparing
ready-wise meals all you need is four
cups of water the water does not need to
be hot
you just pour the food into the water
you stir it you cover it
after about 15 minutes the meal is ready
that is something that even i can
prepare
some meals can even be prepared directly
in the pouch
eliminating the need for additional
surprise so supplies rather and
additional surprises because you don't
want that when things are going south
this is about peace of mind okay
you order it hopefully things don't get
worse than they already are
but you want to know that you are ready
if the time comes this week my listeners
can get free shipping at readywise.com
when entering knowles k
wlas at checkout or by calling 855 453
readywise has a 90-day no questions
asked return policy so there's no risk
taking the initiative to get yourself
and your family prepared today that is
readywise r-e-a-d-y-w-i-s-e-com
promo code knowles k-w-l-e-s to get free
shipping gorsetti has a pretty weak
response to all of this
garcetti says to the new york times in
response to this viral video
my heart goes out to ms morrison and the
workers at the pineapple hill saloon
who have to comply with state and county
public health restrictions
that close outdoor dining no one likes
these restrictions
but i do support them as our hospital
icu beds fill the capacity
and cases have increased by 500 we must
stop this virus before it kills
thousands of more angelinos
that's not an answer buddy because
her problem isn't even that you've shut
down the outdoor dining
it's that you've only shut down some
outdoor dining you've shut down her
outdoor dining but then you've permitted
other outdoor dining to crop up directly
next to her
no one is saying that if the policies
were coherent
then we would have them what we're
saying is these policies are completely
incoherent
one day we're told you can't wear the
masks the next day we're told you have
to wear the masks
one day we're told you can't go outside
you certainly can't protest
against the lockdown restrictions the
next day we're told you need to go
gather on mass by the thousands
to go protest for blm
or protest with antifa we're told by
these
these scoundrels like eric garcetti that
we all have to make sacrifices we all
look we all have to these politicians do
not believe in this
they don't abide by their own mandates
and they don't fear the virus
if they feared the virus then gavin
newsom wouldn't go to the french laundry
and yuck it up with all his buddies
shoulder to shoulder no masks
indoors and then come out and pretend oh
gosh
what a lapse of judgment oh i what an
accident nancy pelosi wouldn't show up
masculist to her hair salon
chris cuomo wouldn't pretend to be
quarantining with the virus
actually go bike riding in the hamptons
get into a fight with one of his
neighbors because one of his neighbors
made fun of him called him out for lying
on television then lie about it on tv
again
all of these people thought she wouldn't
be caught with his mask down time and
time again
these guys do not believe it they do not
fear the virus
in the alarmist way that they are trying
to get you to fear the virus so
obviously the left has been pushing fear
from the very beginning here
they don't believe their own warnings
but now some
liberals are going even further right
because the the alarmism is wearing off
so now there's a
subtle shift in the argument what
they're suggesting is that it's
unpatriotic frankly it's unmanly
not to wear the mask a pete davidson
he's the guy who made fun of dan
crenshaw on snl
pete davidson just advanced this line of
argument also
on saturday night live where he said
it's
people who aren't wearing the masks who
aren't abiding by the arbitrary and
capricious lockdown rules
you know they're just kind of being
babies i take it that you found these
protests frustrating
yeah man they're making us look like
babies you know you know it's bad when
even people in boston are like ah
drink it home your quiz
and do you think that people should stay
at home until the pandemic gets better
yeah everyone wants to go have fun but
there's plenty of stuff you could do at
home
like use your official pete davidson
vibrator
so then at the end it's a callback to a
sex toy but it's a
it's a non-sequitur right and it's it's
something you see often in left-wing
humor
is when they run out of the point they
just go to something
grotesque and usually sexual but it's
not it doesn't follow that isn't good
comedy writing right it doesn't there's
no
there's no payoff there and even what is
what is the
i mean the argument is stay home alone
and that will make you manly and mature
don't go out and see people because
going out and socializing
and living your life and not living in
fear
is somehow childish doesn't work
snl has not been funny for a very long
time very rarely has it been funny over
the past 20 even 25 years
but this i don't even think left wingers
would suggest that this bit was funny
and the reason it's not funny is because
it's divorced from reality
when people watch something that's funny
what's what's the line that you'll often
hear people say
it's funny because it's true right but
when it's when something rings so
obviously
false then it isn't funny because it's
all ideology
an ideology is this abstraction that
tries to recreate reality and the
less connected the ideology is from
reality the less
it will resonate with you and the less
funny these sorts of jokes
will be they don't believe it by the way
they don't even believe it
there was a liberal tick talker who
showed up to
one of president trump's rallies down in
georgia and
the the point he was making was to shame
trump
supporters into wearing the mask and i
don't think there's any question which
person is manlier in this particular
exchange
but i think it's pretty obvious that
they don't even believe their own
argument you know
this is a real gem of a video this is a
real
jewel because it shows you exactly where
the left goes wrong and if you're
interested in jewelry this holiday
season
it's one of the most popular gifts you
can possibly give there's good reason
for that
you should absolutely check out the
pearl source you know
pearl jewelry is wonderful it's lovely
sweet little elisa loves it it doesn't
need to break your budget though
at the pearl source you can get very
fine pearl jewelry highest quality for
up to 70 percent
off retail prices why because the pearl
source cuts out the middle man by
eliminating traditional
5x markups by jewelry stores and selling
directly to you the consumer
the holidays are fast approaching
shipping carriers have an unprecedented
amount of volume do not wait the pearl
source offers fast and free two-day
shipping
on every order with zero contact
delivery plus with more than 20 years in
the pearl business
and nearly 10 000 five-star reviews you
can be sure
that you are shopping from a trusted
retailer as someone who i actually have
gone about
pearl earrings for sweet little lisa
before when you go into the shop
they charge you so much more money you
can get
superb quality and save a lot of them i
save up to 70 off retail prices go to
the pearl source for that
for a limited time listeners to my show
can take 20
off your entire order for the holidays
go to theprosource.com
knowles enter promo code knowles at
checkout for 20 off your entire order
if you want fine pearl jewelry at the
best prices online go straight to the
source the pearl
source the prosource.com slash knowles
enter promo code knowles at checkout
uh we've got a lot to get to here you've
got to check out
this exchange between the liberal tick
talker the mask wearer
and the extremely manly trump supporter
the ways in which people are pushing
back
on this sort of thing now and the ways
in which the left is undercutting even
their own argument when it comes
to the vaccine but first guys
we have a new leftist ears tumbler okay
we have got a brand new and improved
leftist years tumblr
first time we've ever updated the tumblr
the reason for that is
after years and years of use guzzling
delicious leftist ears
occasionally a little bit of a little
bit of the color will chip off of the
old leftist tears tumbler
especially if you're putting it in the
dishwasher every single day the new
leftist year's tumbler
totally dishwasher safe it will allow
you to guzzle your leftist ears not just
for a few years
but in my view for a few decades a very
very snazzy join daily wire or upgrade
your membership to get
this absolutely wonderful tumbler
go check it out you know the michael
knowles show is now five days a week
we're adding the entire
u catalog to daily wire which is great
because i host a show at prager you call
the book club we've got candace owens
coming we've got all sorts of stuff head
on over subscribe to daily wire we'll be
right back with a lot more
so this left winger shows up to a trump
rally and harasses the trump supporters
why won't you wear the mask you guys got
masks
no nope why not
because i don't need it why do you need
it i
would yeah you should wear one because
there's a pen there's a global pandemic
going on
yeah well you got yours i got mine on
yeah i'm trying to be safe
okay but you could infect somebody else
and and they could get sick why aren't
you leaving the line
would you please will you please run
excuse me will you please wear a mask no
please nope for the sake of other people
please wear one please i'm begging you
please
no no i don't think so i don't think so
how pathetic is that dude he's
pathetic and unmanly but he's also
he's also deceitful and dishonest
because on the one hand how to abase
yourself to get down and begging you
please wear the mask please do it and
that guy
that just extremely cool trump
supporters just like nah
with the masks they'll make you safe
okay well you got a mask right so you're
safe
no the masks it's not that the masks
protect the wearer
the masks protect everybody else oh okay
so if that guy really believed that
if that liberal tick talker really
believed
that one this virus was extraordinarily
deadly
and he a apparently healthy millennial
was at great risk
from this virus and b
that the masks don't protect the wearer
the only way the wearer of the mask is
protected is if everyone else is wearing
the masks
then this guy basically just walked into
a a
hive of poison right because he the
whole point of the video is he's going
to show up and all these trump
supporters are not going to be wearing
masks
and he's going to beg them please wear
the masks but that means that he would
have to think that he's he's walking to
his death
because we know the virus is going to
kill everybody right
we know that if if someone else is not
wearing the mask then you no matter
whether you're wearing the mask or not
are at great risk
so this guy's walking to his death so
he's got to be a maniac right
no he just doesn't believe it none of
these people believe it
when they get down and they pester you
and they bother you and they fly across
the country
to go find you to pester you what
they're trying to do
is get you to acquiesce to their will
it has nothing to do with a virus it has
nothing to do with public health
has nothing to do with compassion it's
just
a pure power play
by people who are even willing to abase
themselves to do it like this man
some people manly people are ignoring
these sorts of
rules disobeying them actually is a
better term sheriff
don barnes in orange county california
the great orange hope of that state says
quote
the ever-changing nature of these orders
and the increase of covid19 case numbers
bring additional uncertainty and stress
to california residents
the orange county sheriff's department
will remain consistent in our approach
orange county sheriff's deputies will
not be dispatched to
or respond to calls for service to
enforce compliance with face coverings
social gatherings or stay-at-home orders
only
deputies will respond to calls for
potential criminal behavior
and for the protection of life and
property our actions remain consistent
with the protection of constitutional
rights in other words gavin newsom
two words and they're not happy birthday
absolutely courageous stand absolutely
coherent stand absolutely
constitutional stand absolutely
scientific stand for that matter
resisting this kind of scientifically
and medically illiterate overreach
outrageous overreach so the left is run
out of arguments now what do they do
you know what they do what happens when
the left runs out of even its own flimsy
arguments
to get you to comply with whatever they
want they call you
a racist right that's obviously that's
how you know that you've won the
argument is when a left winger calls you
a racist
or a sexist or a misogynist
and a chicago teachers union is
exhibiting
all three of those strategies in one so
the a-f-t-i-f-t local number one
this is a teachers union represents 28
000 teachers
and support staff in chicago schools
they don't want to go back to work from
the very beginning
even the experts the public health
experts have said there's no reason to
keep schools shut down
the transmission of the virus from the
kids to other kids and then from the
kids to their
parents and grandparents is relatively
quite low we need to keep the schools
open there's
absolutely even the the experts said no
no scientific reason to keep them closed
but the teachers don't want to go back
to work teachers unions
are fighting to keep the schools closed
because the teachers unions
work for the teachers not the students
and not the parents
they don't have any argument anymore to
keep the schools close so they tweet out
yesterday
the push to reopen schools is rooted in
sexism
racism and misogyny and i think
this teachers union actually is teaching
something they're teaching
students how to make up excuses
that in this politically correct culture
are unassailable so you know
a student could read that and and
justifiably
come home and say you know mom the push
to make me finish my broccoli is rooted
in sexism
racism and misogyny you know the
push to make me do my homework
that push historically it is rooted in
racism
sexism and misogyny there's no way
there's no way to refute
this stupid declaration other than to
laugh at it but i think i'm going to
start employing that too
the push to keep the schools closed
is rooted in sexism racism and misogyny
now they cry racism they cry sexism they
cry misogyny on the left
but then they seem to change their tune
when the races or the sexes
change so from the from the beginning
we've been told
the conservatives are science deniers
you've got these
wacky liberals getting down on their
knees to trump supporters please wear
the mask please comply
please follow the experts follow believe
science don't be a
anti-vaxxer science denier
now jake tapper brings up this issue
with a public health expert
and says what happens when certain
people refuse to take the vaccine
a new pew research poll out on friday
suggests that less than half
of black americans say they will get a
cronus virus vaccine
if one were available today i want you
to take a listen to 52 year old carmen
bailey from cleveland ohio
to me it's too early um
you know we don't know any kind of side
effects from them
so i i just really feel like at this
point we're
it's people that's gonna take that
vaccine as guinea pigs
oh man oh man
tapper must be salivating at how he's
going to rip this woman you know
frankly to me she seems somewhat
reasonable she's skeptical of the
experts who've gotten everything wrong
and she's skeptical of the government
which is usually deceitful and
duplicitous but
that's just me jake tapper hates these
anti-science anti-vaxx
people they're they're mass murderers
there's an op-ed actually that came out
in usa today
said that the the covid spreaders are
are mass murderers they're serial
killers so you know jake tappers could
come in he's going to say this
dumb science probably a trump supporter
this woman
has no reason to oppose the vaccine
she's endangering all of us all right
jake let it rip
now this doesn't this kind of skepticism
doesn't occur in a vacuum the u.s has an
ugly racist history when it comes to
science and medicine and black americans
how specifically does operation warp
speed intend to
address this skepticism especially the
disproportionate skepticism in the black
community
what no no jake jake you've been telling
me
from the beginning of this ridiculous
lockdown that if i in any way question
the lockdown
i am a science denier i am a i'm a
wicked dumb
stupid uneducated person who's
endangering everybody else
but then this lady comes out and says
exactly the same thing
and you say this doesn't occur in a
vacuum it's totally justifiable we
should all be skeptical
just because she has a different skin
color than i do
and that frankly even i'm sicilian so
you know it's a little bit more in the
middle it's a little swarthy
so maybe he would take me half seriously
he'd half allow me to do it
sicilians have had a difficult history
in this country as we all know
that exposes for me
the last hint of coherence
because at least the one thing they had
been talking about from the beginning on
the left
cuomo had been saying believe science
follow the experts that was the
sort of the last bastion they don't even
believe that
they don't even believe that you have to
follow the experts
if you have the right skin color or if
you have if you have the right genitals
then you're allowed
to think whatever you want it is utterly
incoherent
there is no reason to listen to a word
that these people say
there's no reason to follow a single one
of their capricious rules
before we go speaking of
extremes and skepticism and nuance
i can't believe i have to say this
there was an op-ed in the new york times
that i somewhat enjoyed
i i almost want to end the show right
there before i i don't i hate that i
have to say that
but nick kristoff in the new york times
published an op-ed that i sort of
enjoyed it's about
internet porn it's called the children
of pornhub
subheader why does canada allow this
company
pornhub i guess the largest right i
think the largest porn company in the
world
why does why does canada allow this
company to profit off videos of
exploitation
and assault and the article begins
pornhub prides itself on being the
cheery winking face of naughty
the website that buys a billboard in
times square and provides snow
plows to clear boston streets it donates
to organizations
fighting for racial equality and offers
steamy content free to get people
through covet 19 shutdowns
that supposedly wholesome pornhub
attracts 3.5 billion visits per month oh
my gosh
more than netflix yahoo or amazon
pornhub raises
or rakes in money from almost three
billion ad impressions a day
one ranking lists bornhab is the 10th
most visited website in the world
yet there's another side of this company
it's infested with rape videos
it monetizes child rapes revenge
pornography spy cam videos of women
showering racist and misogynist content
and footage of women being asphyxiated
in plastic bags a search for girls under
18 no space or 14 year old
or 14yo leads in each case to more than
100 000 videos
most aren't of children being assaulted
but too many are you get the point
this brings us back to a debate that
actually started last december
and it kind of split the right what to
do about
the online porn problem you had people
who
in the name of a very degraded and
shallow understanding of libertarianism
said nah porn's great george washington
and thomas jefferson would love it
they basically wrote the declaration of
independence and the constitution
so that we could all watch videos of
this
trash this wicked and debased stuff
and so we got to keep pouring no
regulations and then you had another
side saying we need to ban porn
just ban it this is obviously horrible
stuff just ban the porn right now
and this debate ensued and
i i thought both sides sort of missed
the point
it gets to a lot of our public debates
right now actually right to the top of
the show we were talking about
do you defend trump or do you defend
georgia how about
both how about you do both how about you
allow trump to pursue his legal options
and encourage him to pursue his legal
options and don't encourage him to
concede
and then how about you also try to hold
the senate by voting for those two
georgia senators
why can't you do both i think on the
porn debate
we can acknowledge there is no
constitutional right to pornography
pornography has been
highly regulated if not outright illegal
from the very beginning of the country
we all we still have laws against
obscenity we jailed pornographers as
recently as a dozen years ago
the founding fathers made a very clear
distinction between liberty and
licentiousness
okay and they did not support
licentiousness and they realized that
licentiousness like pornhub
is the opposite of true liberty that it
actually undermines liberty okay that's
that's the one hand on the other hand
from the banned porn people
i think it's also worth remembering that
conservatives are prudent
we have a practical quality to ourselves
it is not possible to eliminate lust
from the heart of man
it's also not possible to eliminate the
expressions of that lust
this is why the the some of the greatest
theologians and moral thinkers in
history saint augustine
and saint thomas aquinas actually
defended legal prostitution
not because they thought legal
prostitution was a good thing but
because they acknowledged that it's the
world's oldest profession it actually
predates politics
just barely i guess you might say it's a
form of politics the two seem very
similar
and augustine and thomas's point
was that if you eliminated prostitution
entirely
the the entire civilization would be
convulsed with lust and so
what you had to do is regulate it you
know put put it
in one area a red light district for
instance uh
and treat it seriously as the danger
that it is but also recognize that it's
im impractical probably impossible to
get rid of it
entirely why can't we have that
conversation i think once we eliminate
the kind of
stupid idea that we have a natural or
constitutional right to look at porn
and we also eliminate the imprudent and
imp impractical idea
that you can utterly eliminate porn we
can have a real conversation which is
that
this is obviously a major problem
confronting the country
you've got well especially in this
generation you've got kids who have been
exposed to this young boys
from very early age they get hooked on
it it warps their brain
it warps their lives it creates an
addiction that a lot of people want to
get away from
how about you can look at the number of
people in this country
there was some study it said 93 or 94
of men have looked at online pornography
and of course the
typical rejoinder to that is and six
percent of men are liars
you know this is it basically is a
ubiquitous problem
so how about you deal with that and say
yeah this is this is bad this is
this is different than having a playboy
under your bed in the 1970s
this is the the ubiquity of it the ease
of use the the
uh stimulation of it is is a distinct
problem
and then heavily regulated you know if i
wanted to go buy a playboy down the
street
i would have to go and show an id
why do we not have the same mechanism
for
online porn like like a website like
pornhub
to say we're not going to completely
outlaw the thing but you have to you
have to upload an id because
in that case it's not just saying only
adults can get it i
actually don't think adults should be
able to easily access it either it
introduces an element of shame
you have to show an id and therefore
you're saying
i am openly going to be looking at this
kind of material which is very shameful
that would reduce the number of people
who do it now you might have people
making fake ids you might have people
getting around the rules
sure okay right but
as as conservatives especially we should
know better than anybody
that you can't let the perfect get in
the way of the good you can't let
ideological purity get in the way of
practical results
you can't let these abstractions get in
the way of prudence
if you could reduce this problem a
problem that's so bad that even
left wingers in the freaking new york
times are observing it now
it's not just the church ladies you know
wagging their fingers
it's not just puritans and prudes
wagging their fingers
everybody is recognizing this is a
problem
why not arrive at a sort of prudent
solution
that that is a central conservative
insight is
prudence and i think we ought to apply
it to fraught public policy issues here
this is why i often encourage people
not to cling to ideology you know in the
way that some people
just they break their politics down into
three bullet points and they say
no liberty means that i need to go look
at porn all the time no it doesn't
obviously it doesn't
and this applies to the presidential
race too
go win in georgia go go win at the
presidential level at least try
there's no reason not to try and there's
nothing
admirable or virtuous about prioritizing
that kind of abstract purity
over practical results i'm michael
knowles this is the michael show i'll
see you tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer
jeremy boring our technical director is
austin stevens
supervising producers mathis glover and
robert sterling
assistant director pavel wadowski editor
and associate producer
danny d'amico audio mixer robin
fenderson
hair and makeup nika geneva and
production assistant
ryan love the michael knowles show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 20.
hey everybody it's andrew clavin host of
the andrew clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
american republic is collapsing the
end of days is approaching and the moon
has turned to blood but on the andrew
clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clavin
show and laugh your way
through the apocalypse with me andrew
[Music]
clayton